different am a presentation marketer
entrepreneur social media guru internet
personality and agency owner my next
speaker is not afraid to tell it like he
sees it Josh had a college he took his
family wine business and grew it from
three million dollars to sixty million
dollars in just five years
from there he set his sights on
marketing social media and
entrepreneurship with us to discuss the
notion of marketing and the year we live
in is the CEO of digital a nerd agency
vaynermedia thank you
morning I'm really excited to be here as
somebody who has come from outside the
industry over the last seven years I've
become very fond of my contemporaries
and and the creative and strategic
people in this industry and I've enjoyed
it quite a bit my back story is very
immigrant I was born in the Soviet Union
I came to the US we have you know I
lived in a studio apartment a fourth of
the size of this stage with my family my
dad got a job as a stock boy in a liquor
store we were super poor the verse six
seven years of being here and eventually
you know how many people are immigrants
or children of immigrants raising him
awesome so you guys a lot of you know
there's a really hardcore secret
immigrants have it's a tried and true
strategy don't spend money on dumb [ __ ]
and that's what my parents did for the
first five to ten years we've saved and
eventually my dad bought a small liquor
store in Springfield New Jersey this
industry is so interesting to me besides
the last political question most of the
questions that were asked of all these
wonderfully smart people the part that I
was most fascinated by as I watched that
was who gets to be the judge and jury
right who gets to be the judge of
quality who gets to be the judge and
jury has been the number one question
that I've had since I've been through
this is free because you see my story is
simple when you go into a family
business and you're a first generation
immigrant and you have to work for two
bucks an hour's a fourteen-year-old in a
liquor store there's no can lie an award
that justifies your marketing strategy
there's no modeling mix right there's no
subjectivity my KPI was to sell more
Pinot Noir if my marketing worked my
family ate more and had more stuff and
so I come from a background where I
disproportionately respect sales and
marketing in very separate silos but I
find myself in the last decade where a
lot of people mix the two and debate the
two and don't have as much vested
interest as entrepreneurs and business
to actually dissect the two what I'm
excited to talk about this morning is
deploying dramatic common sense in a
20-17 world to an industry that I've had
an unbelievable time getting to know
when I first got here I came out of
building a liquor store from three to
sixty million dollars in five years with
no money how did I do that you have to
make every penny work not only was it
doing three million dollars a year we
were running on 10% gross profit so we
had $300,000 before expenses to make our
business grow I did that because while
sherry Lehman's and zacky's and Sam's
and K&L and wine calm with its 188
million dollars in funding we're doing
the Wine Spectator in The New York Times
and Wall Street Journal and Direct Mail
and outdoor I decided that launching an
e-commerce site in 1996 was a good idea
instead of opening a second store this
is gonna be my second and third store
the other thing I did was I started an
email newsletter in 1996 how many people
here have done or have been close to
email marketing in their career please
raise your hand great you're gonna love
this one in 1996 two hundred thousand
people on my email newsletter and I had
91.3% open rates not because I was a
genius or the copy was so great it was
cuz nobody was email marketing the one
thing I promise you more than anything
more than I know that the Sun will come
up tomorrow I know one true fact
marketers ruin everything it's what we
do two and a half years ago I was so
pumped when I decided that snapchat was
gonna be the next frontier and I
couldn't wait to [ __ ] up that little
ghost you wanted to follow your friends
I wanted to sell you [ __ ] right so
that's been my life email was this new
thing I was like wait a minute I can
reach people instead of doing direct
mail and paying for the paper and paying
for the stamp I can do this and wait a
minute I'm selling the wine Opus one
Chateau Lafite three to four months
ahead of my competition because between
the time they have to make the catalog
and get into your home
I was already in their inbox and here's
the punchline my friends I am NOT a
digital list or a futurist or definitely
not a social media guru what I am is I
really give a [ __ ] about one thing I
have one pitch if you're a baseball fan
I basically create my career much more
to Mariano Rivera than anything else he
was the Yankees closer for 15 years he
had one pitch and nobody could hit it
I've played the same game since I was
six years old when I started my
entrepreneurial career I started a
lemonade stand but I started five of
them I manipulated my friends to stand
behind the lemonade stands all day and
what I did was I walked up and down the
streets of Edison New Jersey it was 1982
different time and I would watch cars
drive and I would this this is how sick
and broken of a human being I am as a
six-year-old I would walk up and down
the streets of New Jersey and I would
sit sit and watch people drive on the
street and try to figure out
which tree or pole was better for me to
put my lemonade stand sign on because I
was following their eyes and basically
the rest of my life has been one
hardcore religion around attention I
don't care about traditional or digital
I stand here today and a lot of people
know me and they think I'm all about
Facebook and snapchat Instagram and I am
but I will stand here today my long-term
plan I've built an agency from 30 that
800 people in the last five years from 3
to 100 million revenue no M&A all growth
but my main goal is predicated on
building a private equity firm on top of
it because while great companies like
the one that presented right before me
can only spend their money on their 7 to
12 monster brands there's ungodly
amounts of great brands in that
portfolio that are gonna be sold off and
I'm gonna buy those grants and I'm gonna
run them through my machine that is my
plan of how I am gonna buy the New York
Jets right that's my strategy so yeah
not so fun right now so so for me what's
been interesting about building my
agency is of it I'm like we're not so
special we're not so great what we are
is we are disproportionately aligned
with our clients because I want to
become our clients my goal is not to run
on the highest margin so I can sell my
agency for eight times
Avada to a [ __ ] Holding Company my
goal is to build an actual business and
what that's done is it's made thank you
thank you so what it's done is it's made
me want to break and rewire my first
corporate America meeting of my life so
in 2006 and 7 I did something super
smart I invested in Facebook and Twitter
very early on and then tumblr and then
uber I'm mainly saying that to humble
brag but it's an important it's an
important thing I decided that this one
pitch that I had because I built Wine
Library on email marketing then the day
that Google AdWords came out I bought
the word wine for five cents a click
before they raised the minimum to ten
cents a click and I sold a lot of wine
as a matter of fact it's the great
regret of my life it is why I will pound
you at some point in my 18 minutes here
on really understanding what's happening
in the Facebook ad ecosystem could
it is the 100% replication of early
Google and I was selling a ton of wine
but I should have put all my money into
it because when you have a
once-in-a-generation arbitrage of
attention that is grossly underpriced by
the market you need to become pot
committed to extract all the value and
even though I grew my dad's business
from 3 to 60 million the truth is and
this is not fun for me to say to you it
should have been 3 to 150 million
because all that Direct Mail money and
all that billboard money and all that
New York Times money should have went
all in to Google because I would
extracted such phenomenal ROI my career
took an interesting turn four months
after YouTube came out YouTube came out
I took a look at it it was another
moment in my life like EECOM like email
marketing like Google AdWords where I
felt it I was like this is gonna be big
and I started a wine show called Wine
Library TV it was the first time that
advertising wasn't driving my revenue it
was content and I was producing a show
the show was pretty basic i sat in front
of a camera for 20 minutes and drank
four bottles of wine best cake I ever
had and at its height hundreds of
thousands of people a day were watching
it and I was selling lots and lots of
wine and that taught me what I've always
know and I want to say this before I go
into the next part of my rant because if
I don't say it it will get lost my
absolute belief is that creative is the
variable of success that the creative is
the variable of success the problem is I
fundamentally do not believe how this
marketplace brings creative to life if
you go home and tell a non marketing
person this story I want to know their
reaction hey Sally best friend let me
actually tell you about my business this
is now the general industry no agency no
brand this is the net score and you know
it here's the bottom line
here's how most brands work in 2017
where they already write a human being
and one or two of her contemporaries
come up with some creative ideas for a
brand they sit in a room they get some
insights they have some strategy but in
general sometimes by the way they come
up with creative ideas
humans three five six seven they then
narrow down their five to seven ideas to
one to two maybe three because you know
the meeting to pitch this only has a
certain amount of time the person on the
other end is normally by high percentage
somebody who went to business school and
was taught to run a P&L and a business
that person sits in a room let's the
other person present they watch a couple
of videos talk about others caca manian
horseshit and then and then those two
people at the top the brand person and
the creative person from that agency
those two human beings decide what the
creative is for the brand now what's
interesting about that creative is it
has to be 100% vanilla you know why
because when they deploy that creative
sixty to seventy percent of the money
maybe fifty but probably closer to 70 if
you factor in the other channels besides
television but fifty percent of that
money is spent in the form of making a
30-second video that 30-second video in
2017 is deploy the following way it
plays in between television linear
television let's get really honest here
for one second friends by show of hands
and remember lying is the devil by show
of hands how many people here in late
2016 when they watch television outside
of live sports watch it on your time not
when it actually airs DVR Tebow on your
time raise your hand a weird everybody
and um all of you that just raised her
hands if you're not doing Netflix and
HBO Go which is by the way the majority
of the emerging trends but if your DVR
because there's an unbelievable content
on network television
how many of you in 2016 fast forward
every single commercial when given the
option raise your hands
yeah all of you and by the way let's all
agree this is not a fourteen-year-old
girl crowd we're old and miraculously
miraculously if that commercial that you
spend 40 50 60 70 we're setting your
money and energy on gets lucky and
actually airs in front of you because I
don't know you drop your [ __ ] remote
off the bed when it airs there's not a
single person here when that thing airs
that doesn't grab this and wants to talk
about what LeBron just did or what she
just wore I promise you one thing you
can count all the impressions you want
for the rest of your life including the
single worst execution of marketing
today which is programmatic digital
banner buying on desktop computers and
you know it because nobody here is going
to women's daily or the bottom left-hand
corner below the fold to see a [ __ ]
banner and so we're playing an attention
game the first meeting I ever went to in
corporate America in South Jersey big
CPG brand I'm super pumped I knew a lot
of people I was very close to Bob killed
Stu for mercy of Nabisco Kraft and
Gillette so I knew the game somewhat
from afar I knew that so many people
that were winning in 2009 after I made
these big internet investments and have
my successful business I knew that I was
gonna have to eat [ __ ] for a decade to
build a client service business to build
a foundation for me to build my thing so
I came in with as much humility as I
could which is hard but I came in I
wanted to listen I was excited and
here's the first meeting I sat in I
promised myself I didn't called my mom I
said mom I'm not gonna say a word I'm
gonna listen I'm gonna do it
walked in
and it's an IAC or an IAT you know lots
of agencies are there and the first PR
agency stands up and this PR agency
tells this brand that they got eighty
eight point three million impressions
for the brand the month before when I
look because I was curious because I
come from digital they counted all of
Huffington Post's monthly traffic the
whole net score for a mentioned
somewhere deep four clicks into that
ecosystem and everybody clapped and then
the next person came some insights type
thing and they said that the Millard
brand study was one of the great things
that they've ever seen in their lives
and everybody clapped and then we
watched the video and everybody got
emotional and clapped and then everybody
clapped and then I looked at the last
page and it said that the brand was down
27% and that's when I thought but I
couldn't go there I said look I know
and by the way everybody's making fun of
me it's 2009 I just put this plan on
Facebook physically with my fingers
they're like isn't that for like my dog
like you know people 2009 is not that
long ago I know you've got a lot of
you've been in the industry you know the
level of disrespect these platforms had
so they make a joke fine and then I just
asked a simple question is how in the
world can we sit in a room for 90
minutes and everything is the greatest
thing we've ever seen and the business
is down 29% and the mmm said we were
getting huge ROI I mean like everything
and then the brand manager and the
senior brand person looked in there like
yeah confusing I'm like it's not [ __ ]
confusing [ __ ]
I'm like it's simple you're scoring the
wrong [ __ ] you can measure any marketing
activity the problem is we have a
process right now that was made from
1950 to 2000 there's a new world
attention is in different places I could
care less if Facebook Instagram snapchat
exists tomorrow I just care about where
your attention is how in a world where
we know that following which is every
single passenger in a car today is
looking at their phone [ __ ] 25 percent
of the people that are driving are
looking at their phone and outdoor media
prices go up because that's what always
happens because there's trying to
squeeze the last dollars out so I was
always confused I was confused I was
saying why is this happening first I got
mad at the brand people then I got mad
at the agency it's the whole ecosystem
how many people saw the big short the
movie raise your hand perfect
I never talk in movies my mom scared me
when I was 10 so I don't talk and movie
she said that was bad I'm watching the
big short I'm sitting with my wife and I
just it was the first time I'd ever
talked in a movie we're watching and all
of a sudden I just give her a little
this and go Lizzy this is what's
happening in the advertising industry
everybody knows everybody's just not in
on it from a legal standpoint we're just
in a machine we know what's being scored
I used to be mad at you but now I
understand you can't take this risk this
is how mmm scored inside and you're not
gonna get promoted and what if and we
all know great brands are up you can
show creative but there's a lot of
variables the money important to trade
trends what your competitors are doing
creative is a variable of success it's
just not the only variable of why a
brand would grow so I poker and I go
Lizzy this is happening in the
advertising industry and I'm the guy
with the weird [ __ ] eye
and by the way I'm no hero the only
reason I even tell this truth is cuz my
financial interest isn't vested in
growing my agency it's not vested in
other things I'm just going through my
Northstar I'm trying to figure out which
people in here understand that when you
do the behaviors that make you
successful in a corporate fortune 500
company today you are completely going
against what will make you successful in
a corporate fortune 500 company 10 to 15
years from today I tell my friends that
I get to know ago look I know why you're
doing this you can't take this bet on
snapchat even though you are selling to
13 to 18 year-olds because it's not
scored internally it's not supported by
people to rings above you that's why
you're not doing it you believe it
hell I know that you as a human being
think one thing about marketing and
selling but when you put on your
business jersey and go in everyday you
act a different way and I used to be mad
but now I understand now I'm mad at the
CEOs of the biggest companies in the
world because they're creating the
scoring and by the way back to the
attention graph my friends when I buy my
first brand and you will watch me do it
the first thing I'm gonna do is run
multiple Superbowl ads I believe that
the number one underpriced value of
attention in today's marketing world is
the Superbowl because every single
person watches it whether they watch it
during the game or on YouTube the week
before the problem with the current
execution of Super Bowl is the creative
has so much vested interest in being a
showcase for agencies for new clients
and for new employees that were not
making the kind of work in there that
really takes advantage of having all of
America there are so many brands in here
that I spend hundreds of millions of
dollars on CRM over the next decade that
they could accomplish that data
collection and one Super Bowl ad with
the right creative execution to get
everybody to do something in their
funnel but as much as I think the Super
Bowl ad is the greatest buy in the world
literally the second most expensive
commercial in the world is the worst
because as much as we'd like people to
watch commercials though
the Emmys and the Grammys and NASCAR is
just not the same attention behavior
live sports I'm you know a lot of people
didn't hit me up they may you must be
pumped about the NFL ratings I'm like
I'm not I'm not gonna use that 11 of the
18 primetime games have been blowouts
that's why the ratings are down you can
talk about election talk about anything
else like I understand what's happening
so I'm not gonna use that cheap shot and
by the way data logics an unbelievable
company helped all my business but it's
no different than Nielsen's our mill
around it was the report that you
accepted fine but I asked this room this
and by the way a room I've really come
to love because when you do talk about
the cross-section of creative and sales
that's me that's what I love I love this
room what I'm scared about is you're all
playing a game for 2016 that's in your
vested interest as you should because
you're a human being the problem is if
you're not paying attention the game
that we're all gonna be playing in 2026
they're gonna judge you poorly please go
look back at the last three revolutions
industrial revolutions they're people
that got hurt the most look exactly like
the people in this room which was they
were making behavior for the prior game
they were training for basketball and
the world made them play hockey if you
think over and airbnb and all the
director consumer brands are gonna love
the subjectiveness of creative or the
horseshit reporting that has been
accepted within this ecosystem you are
out of your mind and so what is the
punch line the punch line is very simple
we need real comments as I understand
why it feels good to be the holder of
the subjectiveness around the creative
because it justifies why you're even in
the room but it needs to be understood
for example on a you know my creative
started hating me at first because they
thought I was downplaying it I'll play
it in a world that this is now the
television and the television is the
radio if you understand that shift and
you go read the history of the
transition of what happened between the
radio and the television and all the
quotes that the television would never
be a viable medium compared to the radio
or you couldn't do the same creativity
this is just history repeating itself
over and over and over
the creatives of those beautiful videos
we watched there was seven more versions
of that video and guess what if you
actually make creative for this world
and you don't do you know everybody
likes to talk about the media
inefficiencies and transparencies what
about the creative what about the
creative the record that's always wanted
to blow something up so that's why
they're doing it what about the creative
that always wanted to meet John Legend
that's why he's in the commercial what
about the hidden costs and out-of-pocket
at scale
come on guys we know this I know you
know it I now know why nobody's talking
about it
because we as human beings have to do
what's right for us good I'm fine I
understand but it doesn't mean that
you're marketing properly but it doesn't
mean that it's right and there's so much
opportunity it's just black and white
when people ask me what work are you
proud of the work that's old [ __ ] black
and white you want to prove that
creative works great Facebook is the
birth child of Direct Mail and
television used hand in hand
it is obnoxious I can prove to you on
any CPG brand by getting no data back
from our retailers because we don't that
it's working because I can run regional
creative against a baseline always
depletion report standard you've got
everybody here's got brands that have
basically sold the same way for the most
part at Albertsons in Michigan for the
last two years run it and see what
happens there is an absolute lack of
want to prove the ROI in the industry
mainly because and this is just the
truth unfortunately and I'm not mad at
the agencies anymore either the
fundamental fact is we have
conglomerates that have both publicly
held traded companies and everybody is
out for their vested interests as they
should
I love capitalism but the fact of the
matter is everybody's trying to run on
their margin and that's what happens and
so there is so much opportunity to tell
our stories that last presentation was
exactly right you just need to get 19
at-bats instead of one at-bat and you
need to run it in a way where the first
four at-bats indicates your next night
at
Batz creatives are gonna be able to get
all nine ideas into the ecosystem and
everybody's like well does it ladder you
know what I love but Carrie when you do
that does it ladder up to the brand who
chooses you Sally you Sally or the only
woman on earth that knows that this is
on brand we have to really understand
that our brands mean different things to
different people we have to understand
that there's a totally different
marketplace and most of all and this is
basic data the attention the attention
of the consumer is shifting at scale if
I told you what was happening today ten
years ago you would not believe it the
power of computing the way we date
remember how taboo internet dating was
right this is a real opportunity doesn't
mean anything is dead this has nothing
to do with dead nothing's dead that's a
matter fact you know what I'm paying
attention to Drive time radio
Drive time radio continues to go down in
price it's eventually gonna get super
interesting I can be sold anything [ __ ]
on my slope signals and carvings and
caves if you sell it to me for zero this
is not about this is better than that
this is about if you were agnostic if
you were unemotional what's a better
deal than the other you could be up
thirteen people always tell me but Gary
I'm crushing it on TV and programmatic
that's what you're there like and I'm up
13% I'm like hey Rick what's wrong with
upbeat 44% that's the punchline and the
opportunity is there and the truth is
I've come to realize and I'm happy about
this I know all of you know so now the
question is who's brave enough to have
the real conversations internally to
give you some room some room to actually
do it the world's clearly changing and
too many people in this room are holding
on to the past because it is in their
vested financial interest that's fine
and I appreciate it I'm not saying
you're bad I'm saying please just keep
in the back of your mind
that that's for the current game we're
playing and they're gonna pull the rug
from underneath you and you need to know
that thank you
Samri thank you I said it was going to
be different so I don't know why that
would be different because at 3 o'clock
in the morning after I pump a couple of
bottles of rose' into them at can they
say the same [ __ ]
the kratom gets elevated when we accept
an eco system that gives us more
creative at-bats this is not created
I believe creative the most I just think
that an African American with four kids
in Houston that's forty four years old
is going to think differently about the
creative than Sally in Alaska that's
single in twenty six and we play an
ecosystem where we just push and then we
throw four cents at some interpretation
of it we are completely disrespecting
attention which it I have no idea but I
don't you know why because we see brands
are knocking it out of the park because
four trades give them credit like this
is subjective [ __ ] you knows knocking
another park the people that are deeply
putting rigor around their actions for
sales sour patch kids because we worked
on it I know go figure
here's the punchline this was wild when
you take Sour Patch Kids which sells to
twelve to eighteen year olds when you
take it away from running a commercial
on Spike TV that cost you eight hundred
thousand dollars to make the commercial
when you do that and you take all that
money and you pour it into Instagram and
snapchat creative influencers then the
business grows sixty percent sales go
figure
but it's what it's true right it's true
like like if you were running a
commercial for a brand that target
audience is 22 and under you're a
[ __ ]
skin a little jersey up here
people don't get it I don't want the
business I just don't want you to go to
your interview to air B&B in four years
and have that on your resume do you
understand like like come on like do you
understand like this is real do you
understand the channel conflict wars
that are coming between directed
consumer brands and the fortune 500 CPG
companies do you understand when Sally's
toothpaste is doing 200 million direct
to consumer that Colgate says wait a
minute we have to compete with this but
then they can't because Costco and
Albertsons the CBS won't let them go dtc
like there's really stuff coming we've
got to take this way more macro there's
a lot coming you would like everybody
here knows the world's 15 years ago how
many people are retiring in ten years
and i don't mean you're gonna crush it
and get bonuses i mean you're old and
you're finished ten years raise your
hand ten years for four what do you guys
think the world looks like in ten years
it's gonna be 3x the innovation that
we've seen in lat alexa voice ordering
your [ __ ] smart kitchen smart products
reordering itself like if you're not
running on the treadmill right now doing
smart digital to get ready for the
marathon we're all living you're
finished as an executive you know what
else don't you know what else
i've taken in it I'm taking an
interesting turn on this kind of what
really excites me is I've gone the route
of you because I realize how many
decisions are made by you but the
punchline is and you're also helping the
business the executive that goodness
sour patch kids Fork is doing way better
but sour patch kids exploded in sales
but you know listen when your margin as
a media buying agency is very high in
programmatic manner very easy to go to
the upfront at CBS and listen to Kanye
and place media you're gonna push that
that's just the truth and so but doesn't
make it right
the whole thing that's what it is 2,700
people there but guys I'm telling you
gals listen go read the transition of
radio to television it is the biggest
preview for you the biggest brands of
the world went down new brands emerged
the whole beer industry switched because
the emotion and the vested interest of
the media planners of the time in radio
and they took him to the Yankees game
and drank a beer with you know the mick
you know it's a mistake
and again what really blows my mind is I
know you know it now I used to not I
came from Silicon Valley and
entrepreneur land I was like you don't
know you know you're just stuck in the
game that you're playing and I get it
but really to people making a subjective
call on a piece of creative and then
giving it some vanilla punchline like
for the people or hey you can like you
it's never creative I can create every
one of your slogans for next 20 years
let me run a quick algorithm of six
common-sense words together and I'll
give them to you because it has to be
vanilla yeah are you hiring absolutely
because that's the other thing on the
flip side it's been an interesting high
getting to a place with the agency where
we're hiring you know hefty salary
experienced people the experience is so
valuable the creativity is the variable
the strategic thing is the variable it
can that person take away the old habits
and go more of a bottom-up than top-down
mentality right it's tough for a
creative senior creative to not jump in
the room at the last minute and change
something to justify their means when
speed does matter so they're just a lot
of things going on but I think I will
say this the thing we have to change is
the way we're scoring you know like too
many things look good and then aren't
and we're not giving it the rigor
because mmm and creative and the brand
people they're all siloed we have to
come together and just like own it
together and force creative to prove its
actual ROI because so many you know I
was looking at business early on that
was
heralding television but they didn't
mention that they made an enormous
investment in trade to bump up sales
it's like for some reason we have this
emotional attachment to the medium if I
started vaynermedia today we would be an
Alexa message bot top-level domain
strategy vertical video shop that's what
we'd be because I always want to be 12
to 18 months ahead of the market stay
alive through my salesmanship so that
when the markets there you grow okay see
if you can do it I can one minute one
minute left in one minute can you tell
all these people what's the one nugget
you want to leave them with that they
should go back to their offices
one minute you're gonna die I don't know
if you've heard and I'm being dead
serious there's so much opportunity the
people this room can do so much if they
allow themselves to play a game based on
them being self-aware about themselves
and what they want their legacy and
skillsets to deploy against we are in a
rat trap we're in a circle we're all
saying the same thing anytime I need nor
any time I need new business to grow I
go play your game it's that easy I
reverse engineer of the human being
that's gonna make the decision
I let her him dictate the creative and
we go on our merry way and I want to
shoot myself in the face right and then
I start beating them up and saying okay
I sold you now we're doing none of that
right legacy opportunity those things
this is an amazing time to be in this
industry if you're on the offense and
it's the worst time to be honest in this
industry if you're on the defense and
95% of you are on the defense and if
I've got one of you to switch from that
[ __ ] side to offense today then I feel
really good about myself
thank you